the pursuit for the truth behind the
deadliest fire in irish history
survivors and relatives of the victims
of the stardust disaster gathered in
dublin as part of their campaign for
answers
on the evening of valentine's day 1981
48 young people were killed and more
than 200 injured when a fire ripped
through the stardust nightclub in artane
patdon lost her 21 year old brother
brian
such was the intensity of the blaze her
family couldn't bury his remains just
some clothing she remembers the family
receiving the news my mom was a great
woman lovely lady very stoked and she
kind of just sat there
my dad just lost the head
screamed and cried no no no can't be him
it was their baby they almost have seven
so though
the rest of that was called kind of a
blur and we sat down and dad just kept
crying mum just sat there in silence
white face and the rest of us just
couldn't comprehend what had happened
so what caused the star dust fire well
an inquiry in the immediate aftermath
found that the probable cause was arson
that hugely angered the survivors which
saw it as a form of victim blaming it
wasn't until 2009 that a new report
found there was no evidence for arson
then in 2019 the irish government
ordered a new inquest to be held into
the 48 deaths but that still hasn't
started
legal arguments and an issue surrounding
the juror pay has delayed the new
inquest but for samantha mangan whose
mother helena was killed it can't wait
any longer i have five beautiful
children and i can't be the best mum to
them until i know what's happening
because this is like a brick and it's
killing me it feels like there's a
chain around my neck you know what i
mean and i just can't move forward until
i find out what happened to her and why
she didn't come home
the new inquest will be the largest and
longest of its kind in irish history
possibly lasting for four years it
should get underway sometime in march
and bring the stardust families a step
closer to the end of their decades-long
search for answers
stephen murphy sky news in dublin